Good morning, John!
This is officially weird.
Pizzamas!
Lots of videos!
Not only here, but Five Nights at Freddie’s
2 just came out which is a sequel to a video
game that I like a lot.
So I’ve been playing that, editing those,
and uploading them on Games with Hank.
Fair warning, they’re a little scary.
Not that I mind any of this of course.
I love it!
I love Pizzamas!
We have an official lyricist in the comments
and an official emoji combination.
More weird Pizza John things are being created
all the time; it's just a good feeling.
But I realized, in reading the comments to
my last video, that I kind of jumped into
this Pizzamas thing and a lot of people were
a little bit left behind.
If you have no idea what Pizzamas is, raise
your hand.
I don’t really know either.
But let’s do a brief history of the Pizza
John here.
Back in 2010, John and Hank Green would do
BlogTV shows.
That was a live streaming platform that doesn’t
exist anymore.
John, a very busy guy, would often eat during
them because he didn’t have any other time
to do live streams, so he'd do it during dinner.
Nerdfighters started making fun of him.
They made a Facebook group which was just
pictures of John eating stuff.
Everyone thought this was funny, including
John Green.
One of the central things to this entire project
for me has been that you can do serious things,
and also do silly things, and those things
are not contradictory.
The thing that we want to avoid largely is
not seeming like people.
Hi!
I'm a person!
You just gotta hit yourself in the head with
a remote control sometimes.
That’s Puppycat.
I hit Puppycat.
This bell calls down an intergalactic Temp-bot,
played by Hannah Hart.
If you haven’t seen Bee and Puppycat yet,
you need to see Bee and Puppycat right now,
it is so good.
The world is complicated, and understanding
it is important.
But if you don’t have a good time, you’re
not gonna have a good time.
And you can quote me on that.
So in 2011, when you made a video Pakistan
while shaving your Movember beard slowly and
somewhat grotesquely, it culminated in like
3 seconds of you having a mustache.
John: MMMMMustache!
And crazy eyes and big hair.
A nerdfighter took a screencap of that, put
it up on the internet, people laughed at it.
And then another nerdfighter, Valerie2776,
who now works for us as our community manager,
did like some contrast stuff, traced it in
Illustrator, made it white on red, and that
was Pizza John.
She put it up on her blog.
John, you saw it and you said this:
John: I don’t know why I love that, but
I know I want it as a shirt.
And so we put it on a shirt.
And some people bought it.
Not a lot of people, but some people.
But this Pizza John face is so like weird
and recognizable and bold and somehow fitting
into the nerd aesthetic in a way that you
don’t really understand.
And also requiring just a little bit of bravery
to even wear in public that it became kind
of like a nerdfighter badge.
Pizza John shows up in a lot of places, and
it's pretty cool to see him showing up in
a lot of places.
Why Pizza John?
How did it happen?
I don’t know.
Things like this happen and we want to explain
them, but we can’t.
And really, if we could It would be less special.
So what is Pizza John?
Why is Pizza John?
I don’t know.
I don’t...I don’t know.
In any case, a few years ago, we decided that
Pizza John is popular enough that we’d make
some new Pizza Johns that would be limited
edition designs of Pizza John.
We called it Pizzamas, and that was that.
There were no extra videos.
Then last year we did it again, except instead
of with different designs, we did it with
different products.
Now we’re doing it again with both different
designs AND different products.
And also extra Vlogbrothers videos.
We just want more; we just want to experience
it a little more deeply.
And also remember that it’s been a long
time.
And that things have changed a lot, but not
the important things.
This is a video project between two brothers
talking to each other, even though their lives
now are a lot weirder than they used to be.
And it's a community of people who have some
shared values.
Valuing equality, and the knowledge that the
world is complicated and it deserves to be
understood complexly.
Sometimes people ask me how long I'm going
to be doing this for, like what’s your five
year plan?
Where you going from here?
Kind of thing.
And I'm like ‘Are…are you kidding?
I will be doing this forever!’
That’s the plan.
81 year old Hank.
Toothless, mumbling about Pizzamas 2061.
I'll see you then.
John, I’ll see you tomorrow.